Bitte schön.
Guten Abend. Leider ist mein Name und ich bin eine der Stationserster.
Heute bin ich für Sie zuständig und würde jetzt bei Ihnen dieses Aufnahmegespräch durchdrehen,
wenn Sie damit einverstanden sind.
Ja, ich bin damit einverstanden.
Jetzt werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Personen stellen.
Ich habe da nicht verstanden.
Was möchten Sie bitte für Ihre Person stellen?
Ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Personen stellen.
Zu Ihrer Person.
Ja, danach werden wir sofort über Ihre aktuelle Bischoferden sprechen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Fritz Müller.
Ja, könnten Sie mit Ihrer Vorname und Nachname buchstabieren?
Also Fritz ist ganz einfach.
F R I T 6 Fritz.
Und Müller M Ö L L E R Müller.
Und die Arztin?
Ja, ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1 Meter 73 groß.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ungefähr 86 Kilo.
Und was willst du zu uns, Herr Müller?
Also ehrlich gesagt, seit ungefähr einer Woche fühle ich mich sehr schlapp.
Ich bin müde, kann kaum mehr Treppen steigen.
Und ich fühle mich völlig ausgelaufen.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit mir los ist.
Seit einer Woche?
Ja, hatten Sie auch irgendwelche Matzenübel?
Haben Sie sich schon übergeben?
Also eine Bischoferde hatten Sie auch?
Also Übelkeit hatte ich nicht.
Erbrochen habe ich auch nicht.
Ich habe sonst nicht verstanden, was Sie gefragt haben.
Haben Sie Schmerzen auch?
Schmerzen habe ich keine, nein.
Okay.
Und so, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ja irgendeine Erkältung gehabt?
Erkältung?
Nein, kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern.
Hatten Sie Feber?
Oder haben Sie das überhaupt gemessen?
Hab ich nicht gemessen, aber es kam mir nicht vor, als wenn ich Feber gehabt habe.
Okay, dann haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches gegessen?
Was Ungewöhnliches gegessen?
Nein, ich esse immer eigentlich das, was ich sonst auch mal essen.
Und so, haben Sie Versturzungenprobleme?
Ne.
Versturzungen, Durchfall?
Durchfall habe ich nicht, nee.
Oder haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Oder schon haben Sie es erzählt, aber haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ne, Probleme beim Wasserlassen habe ich auch nicht.
Okay, aber seit einer Woche fühlen Sie sich schlamp.
Ja, seit einer Woche ungefähr, ja.
Das hat so letzte Woche angefangen.
Ja, haben Sie so ähnliche Bischewarten, die schon mal gehabt?
Ne, sowas habe ich bisher noch nie gehabt.
Deswegen bin ich gekommen, weil ich kenne sowas nicht.
Okay, und eigentlich, was für Sie jetzt aktuell schwer,
können Sie mir das sagen?
Noch mal bitte.
Was ist für Sie eigentlich jetzt schwer?
Fühlen Sie sich schlamp, aber was können Sie eigentlich nicht machen
mit diesem Müdigkeit, oder?
Ich bin nicht mehr leistungsfähig.
Ich kann keine Treppen steigen, ich kann nicht mehr richtig laufen.
Ich bin eigentlich ein ganz fitter Mensch gewesen.
Ich bin auch voll gelaufen, habe Sport gemacht.
Jetzt muss ich nach ein paar Metern stehen bleiben,
weil ich keine Luft bekomme.
Okay.
Ja, haben Sie auch Schwierigkeiten beim Atmen?
Manchmal.
Atmenschwierigkeiten?
Atmenschwierigkeiten, nicht nur beim Atmen.
Ne, beim Atmen habe ich keine Schwierigkeiten.
Aber wenn ich Treppen steige oder wenn ich laufe,
habe ich das Gefühl, ich kriege keine Luft.
Okay.
Und dann brauchen Sie ja einmal ein Stuck und einmal einen Ausatmen.
Und danach können Sie wieder diese Leistung weiterführen.
Ne, ich muss ein paar Minuten erst mal stehen bleiben,
mich ausruhen und erst dann geht es wieder weiter.
Okay.
Und ja, das gilt auch beim Laufen, wenn Sie...
Ja, so wie gesagt, das ist schon ein gelbter Weg.
Und dann ist es egal, ob ich Treppen steige,
ob ich draußen spazieren gehe oder laufe.
Das wird mehr und mehr.
Am Anfang habe ich das nicht so richtig gemerkt,
aber dann habe ich gesehen, so seit ein paar Tagen,
ich kann nicht mehr richtig laufen.
Wenn ich ein bisschen laufe, dann kriege ich keine Luft.
Okay.
Und haben Sie schon bemerkt,
dass Sie ja irgendwie eine Beschwollende,
einige Schwollende haben?
Beschwollende Beine?
Ne.
Schon eine Beine habe ich nicht.
Ne, habe ich nicht den Eindruck.
Okay.
Und ja, leiden Sie unter, leiden Sie an eine gründliche Herzkrankheit?
Ich weiß nicht, wie gesagt,
eine blutrauchtere, politische Krankheit oder so,
haben Sie gründliche Krankheit?
Nein, nicht steckleigen.
Ich bin bei mir nicht bekannt.
Kein Bluthochdruck, kein Diabetes.
Und der Herzprobleme habe ich auch nicht.
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Ja, haben Sie Hüsten auch?
Oder haben Sie Hüsten?
Ne, Hüsten habe ich nicht.
Herzrasen, Herzkluchten, manchmal bekommen Sie das?
Oder leben Sie ganz ohne Probleme?
Herzklopfen oder so habe ich nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, in den letzten Tagen habe ich das Gefühl,
auch beim Laufen oder Treppensteigen,
so als wenn mein Herz rast, ich schläge ziemlich schnell.
Und dann muss ich stehen bleiben,
weil ich dann keine Luft bekomme.
Und so, haben Sie schon den letzten beim Arzt gewesen?
Sind Sie schon?
Nein, ich komme direkt hierher.
Ich war bisher nie beim Arzt gewesen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Schlafprobleme?
Nein, also Probleme beim Einschlafen habe ich nicht.
Ja, können Sie sich einfach beim hinlegen,
um sich zu schlafen?
Ja, beim Einschlafen habe ich das Gefühl.
Noch einmal bitte, ich habe Sie nicht verstanden.
Ja, aber brauchen Sie auch,
Ihr Körper, Ihr Überkörper vorzuheben beim Schlafen?
Ob ich mit aufrechtem Oberkörper schlafen muss?
Ne, das muss ich nicht.
Ich kann ganz flach liegen.
Okay.
Und so, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie kein Erkrankung haben.
In den letzten Zeiten haben Sie schon lange Reise ins Ausland gemacht?
Ne, im Ausland war ich auch nicht.
Lange Reise?
Ne, jetzt in der lange Reise habe ich auch nicht gehabt.
Haben Sie schon in den letzten Ungewirrt ab oder zu genommen?
Ne, mein Gewicht ist die ganze Zeit stabil.
Und nach dem Schweißausbrüch hatten Sie auch so eine Nähbischewörter?
Ne, nach dem Schweißausbrüch.
Ne, wir nehmen Sie regierenmäßig Medikamente ein.
Hin und wieder mal, wenn ich mal ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen habe,
habe ich mal eine Ibuproféen eingenommen.
Wie meinen Sie auch, wie oft bekommen Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Vielleicht mal so in einer Woche, ein, zwei Stück.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon aufreget worden?
Ne, in der Operation habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ja, bei Ihnen ist ein Allergy bekannt?
Allergy habe ich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Sind Ihre Eltern am Leben noch?
Meine Eltern sind noch am Leben, ja.
Sind Sie gesund, oder seiden Sie am Konchnerkankon?
Ja, das sind schon ältere Menschen, gesund sind sie nicht.
Mein Vater hat ein bisschen Bluthochdruck,
er hat auch Probleme mit dem Herzen.
Und die Mama, die hat mal Mama-Karzinom gehabt
und auch mal einen kleinen Schlaganfall.
Aber momentan geht es beiden gut.
Okay.
Ihr Vater, haben Sie schon erzählt,
dass er eine Herzproblem hat.
Und welche Herzproblemen konnten Sie genau sagen?
Der hat mal einen Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Und jetzt muss er Wassertabletten einnehmen,
seine Beine werden dick.
Ich glaube, der Arzt hat ihm gesagt, der hat eine Herzschwäche.
Okay.
Und arbeiten Sie noch?
Ich arbeite noch, ja.
Und was machen Sie von Beruf?
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Teamleiter in einem Ingenieur-Büro.
Dann machen Sie meistens Büroarbeit.
Ja, aber ich bin Teamleiter.
Okay.
Und brauchen Sie viel davor zu geben bei der Arbeit?
Noch mal bitte.
Brauchen Sie viel davor zu geben, viel Kraft zu nehmen?
Sie meinen, ob ich viel arbeiten muss,
ob ich viel Stress habe?
Ja, klar.
Ich bin der Verantwortliche für bestimmte Projekte
und das muss laufen.
Und wenn das nicht zeitnah passiert,
dann kommt man schon in Stress.
Und das merke ich schon.
Okay.
Sind Sie feieradet?
Ja, ich bin feierad.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, einen Sohn und eine Tochter.
Sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind gesund, denen fehlt nichts.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Sie ist auch gesund, oder hatte sie auch Probleme?
Nein, sie hat keine Probleme.
Sie geht auch gut.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon in den Listen-Zeiten ein bisschen belästert geworden?
Oder irgendwie Frau, eine etwas Sorge geben,
dass sie ein bisschen bläser sind?
Ich verstehe sie nicht.
Ob ich was bin?
Bläser.
Blasser geworden.
Blass, ein Blasser.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Bisher hat mir das keiner gesagt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Aber Sie überhaupt ja bewusst sein verloren.
Wusstest du, dass ich nicht geworden bin?
Nein.
Okay.
Ich glaube, ich habe alle meine Fragen schon gestellt.
Wenn Sie fragen,
dann habe ich das.
Was habe ich denn?
Diese Möglichkeit.
Er kann viele Ursache haben.
Erst machen wir eine Köcher,
die untersuchen,
eine Blutuntersuchung,
eine Blutab,
dann die Blutab,
dann schauen wir mal,
ob Aufwähligkeiten in der Blutuntersuchung sind.
Dann können wir weiter sprechen,
ob wir weitere Untersuchungen durchführen sollen.
Aber jetzt erst kann ich genauer nicht sagen.
Viele Ursache haben.
Ich muss hier bleiben.
Ja, wir müssen jetzt auf die Seite gehen.
Ja, bis der Ergebnis hierhin gekommen ist.
Okay.
Ja, gut.
Dann warten wir mal den Ergebnis ab.
Okay.
Das war es.
Ich komme sofort auf Sie zu wieder.
Und ja, sprechen wir darauf wieder ausführlich.
Ich komme auf Sie zurück.
Ich komme zurück zu Ihnen.
Und dann besprechen wir die Ergebnisse.
Okay.
Haben denn die anderen Kollegen noch Fragen?
Ja, ich werde jetzt sofort mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen.
Über Sie.
Ja.
Haben die anderen Kollegen noch Fragen,
die Sie an mich stellen möchten?
War Ihnen nicht schwindel?
Schwindel habe ich nicht so richtig bemerkt. Nein.
Müssen Sie öfter was verlassen?
Nein, was verlassen habe ich nicht.
Habe ich kein Problem.
Ihnen war Sausen aufgefallen?
Sausen im Ohr? Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Spüren Sie Brustschmerzen?
Brustschmerzen habe ich auch keine. Nein.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverdäglichkeiten?
Das hatte ich schon beantwortet.
Alle Gien sind mir nicht bekannt.
Kalte Schweiß? Haben Sie Kalte Schweiß?
Noch mal bitte.
Kaltschweiß.
Kaltschweiß, nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Wie sieht es aus Impfstatus?
Sind Sie gegen alle Krankheiten geübt?
Also die gängigsten Sachen, ja,
aber die Impfung legt fast ein Jahr zurück.
Sind Sie vegan?
Ja, das habe ich schon gelesen.
Ob ich veganer bin?
Nein, ich erscheinte auch Fleisch.
Und Heiserkeit oder so?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ja, einzige Auffälligkeit ist,
seit einer Woche,
bestehende Müdigkeit.
Ja, Müdigkeit.
Leistungsknick, leistungsknick.
Ja, Leistungsknick, sagt man ja im Deutschen.
Und Schlappheit, Müdigkeit.
Ich bin so müde, ich muss mich nur hinsetzen.
Dann schlafe ich meistens mal ein.
Und ja, wie ist Ihr Antrieb?
Bitte?
Wie ist Ihr Antrieb?
Wie ist mein Was, bitte?
Antrieb, ja, leiden Sie unter Antrieblosigkeit oder so.
Fühlen Sie sich antrieblos?
Nein, bin ich nicht.
Aber jetzt in einer Woche, ich habe keine Kraft.
Das ist das Einzige.
Wie fühlen Sie sich, ja, depressiv oder so,
irgendwie eine seelische Prosteinigung?
Nein, bin ich nicht bekannt.
Ja, bekannt, okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Ihre Vorsorge untersuchen, nun war.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Ja, gehen Sie regelmäßig Ihr Hausarzt.
Nein, also beim Hausarzt war ich schon seit Ewigkeiten nicht mehr.
Mir geht es eigentlich gut.
Wie gesagt, ich mache auch regelmäßig Ihre Vorsorge.
Ich mache auch regelmäßig Ihre Vorsorge.
Mir geht es eigentlich gut.
Wie gesagt, ich mache auch regelmäßig Sport
und ich war auch nicht beim Hausarzt.
Okay.
Seit langem, ja, waren Sie nicht beim Haus gewesen.
Wie lange war das?
Wie viele Jahre schon?
5, 6 Jahre, bestimmt schon.
Rauchen Sie trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, okay, ja.
Ich brauche nicht.
Ich bin ganz selten Alkohol.
Und haben Sie Erfahrung mit dem Drogen?
Drogen?
Nein, mit Drogen habe ich nichts am Hut.
Ja, können wir als Gespräch anfangen.
Ja, wenn sonst keine Leute anfangen.
Dann sehen wir,
wie ihr das finden könnt.
Hallo Herr Oberhaus, ich habe heute
einen Patienten aufgenommen.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben,
dann würde ich gerne vorstellen.
Ja, klar.
Okay. Hamilla, 63er Patient.
Ich stelle sich vor,
wegen der Corona-Krise,
ich stelle sich vor,
wegen der, ja, seit einer Woche bestehende
Müdigkeit.
Eigentlich, das war einzige Aufwähligkeit,
die die Anamnese
sich ergab
und
als welche der Diab,
Anamnese ergab sich auch,
keine Aufwähligkeit.
Ich habe keine Vorerkrankungen,
eine Nehme abzubehen
oder zwei, drei Mal pro Röhre
überprüfen, weil wir da gegen Kropfschmerzen
und ja,
manchmal bekommt er
Luft,
Luftnot oder ja, er braucht
auch viel auszurufen,
wenn
unter Belastung oder viel
beim Krippensteigern
oder so ähnliche Belastungs-
Belastungs-
unter Belastung, ja, brauche er
ein Pause.
Sonsten,
aber
Alkohol trinke er gelegentlich,
keine Erfahrung mit den Drogen.
Nein, das stimmt aber nicht.
Also, wissen Sie, was der Unterschied zwischen gelegentlichem
Alkoholkonsum und seltenem Alkoholkonsum ist?
Ja, okay.
Ja, wenn wir sagen,
einmal ja, dann ist das selten,
dann trinkt er seltenen Alkohol.
Wenn Sie gelegentlich sagen, heißt es
für Sie, dass er, was weiß ich,
einmal eine Woche, einmal im Monat
oder mehrmals eine Woche trinken.
Ja, bei jeder Möglichkeit.
Ja, Sie müssen schon aufpassen, wie Sie das formulieren.
Wenn Sie Kultur hören, dann machen Sie aber nicht den Fehler.
Wenn er sagt, einmal im Jahr, dann ist das selten,
ja, fast gar nicht.
Okay.
Und
bei den
Patienten,
sei keiner da gebekannt
und ja in der Familienanamnese
seinen Vater
ja leider an atrientliche
Patonie und ja, er habe
schon
einen Katinfektinfarkt gehabt
und ja,
und behandelt für auch
Herzinsuffizienz aktuell
und sein Mama
schon Mama Katzinung gehabt
und behandelt wurden
und er hat einen Tag am Fall Apoplexie gehabt
und er arbeitet als
Teamleiter in
engenia
als engenia
Ingenieur
und ja,
er berichtet über auch
Fehler, Interesse in der Arbeit, bei der Arbeit
und
ja, verdacht diagnostisch
denke ich an,
denke ich erst an, ja,
die begehende
Herzinterventionz
da ja,
ja, leidet er
unter Belastung an
Luftnot oder
so eigentliche Bescheide
und jetzt
bei der Untersuchung körperlichen Untersuchung Beine und Dämmer
oder so eine Bescheide finden kann
ja, das kann ich meiner
Diagnose verstecken
und
haben Sie den dann noch nicht untersucht? Da machen Sie das bitte? Nein.
Ja, dann untersuchen Sie den
bitte, aber
Sie sehen, der Mann hat keine Unterschenkel-Othema
ja, aber er richtet über keine
ja, hat keine Unterschenkel-Othema
und beim Auskultieren der Lunge
beim Abhören, hören Sie auch keine Rassel-Geräusch
und
Blutuntersuchen
soll durchgeführt werden unbedingt
ja, aber
bei der körperlichen Untersuchung machen Sie nur
das Herz und die Lunge
oder machen Sie auch noch etwas anderes? Ja, Bauch-Untersuchung
soll ich auch. Ja, aber was machen Sie denn,
wenn Sie den Bauch untersuchen?
Abtasten, Abhören
und der Auskultation,
abtasten oder drücken in den Bauch
drücken in den Bauch, ja. Wie teilt man den Bauch ein?
Ja, es gibt
wie ich wusste, zwei unterschiedliche
Kategorisations, eine
vier, dann können wir vier Korderan
teilen
oder unteren und rechten linken Korderan
und auch neun
Teilhaut können wir teilen.
Das ist schon korrekt, die vier Quadranten sind das übliche,
was so in Deutschland benutzt wird, aber
man macht noch den Unterschied mit dem Epigastrium
man sagt, die Quadranten untersuchen,
aber Epigastrium wird gesondert genannt, ja.
So, jetzt haben Sie den Mann untersucht
und ohne dass der Mann das angegeben hat
hat der Schmerz in dem Epigastrium
wenn Sie da drauf drücken tut es im Weh
was er vorher nicht bemerkt hat.
Okay.
Das kann auch eine
Maggenprobleme hindeuten
oder das kann auch auf
eine, ja, Erstprobleme auch hindeuten.
Ja, das ist ja auch ein Problem
für die
ja, aber ja, sagen wir mal, wie gesagt
Herz passt meiner Meinung nach
deshalb nicht, weil er seit einer Woche
ja, der hat keine Unterschenkel-Odemen
und die Luftnot hat mehr und mehr zugenommen
ja, das ist jetzt, er hat keine
Torrakanschmerzen, ja, er hat
keine Palpitationen
und er kann flach liegen
und das alles schlicht gegen Herz.
Natürlich muss man differenzial diagnostisch
an das Herz immer denken, aber wie gesagt
Sie haben im Epigastrium
auf Druck ein Schmerz ausgelöst.
So, jetzt müssen Sie da drauf weiterarbeiten
der nächste Schritt wäre, Sie müssen
erstmal Blut abnehmen, ja, gucken, was Sie
haben überhaupt, ja, was ist da los?
Einmal Colostasoparameter und ja,
amelase Lepase zu, ja, um
Pankreatitis auszuschließen, oder?
Die sind unauffällig.
Und ja,
ein Zündungsparameter
C-A-P-B-S-G.
Die sind auch unauffällig.
Okay,
so, ja, Rheon-Rethansionwerte, Kreatinien
und Rheatinien
Ja, das ist... Ja, was gibt es noch?
Aber Nierenproblem hat er nicht.
Prätenziumwerte sind in Ordnung, Kranstoff,
Kran-Tere, Kreatinien, alles in Ordnung.
Okay, dann...
Was gibt es denn noch im Blut?
Blutuntersuchung
unterscheidet man immer in zwei Gruppen
oder drei besser gesagt.
Was ist das? Einmal die klinische Chemie.
Dazu gehören Elektrolyte,
Nierenwerte, Leberwerte, Pankreaswerte,
Entzündungswerte. Was gibt es noch?
Blutbild gibt es,
ob wir jetzt große oder klein machen
und es gibt noch die Garennung.
Ja, Gernungsfaktor und auch Garen.
Und Blutbild haben Sie gar nicht geguckt.
Was sieht man im Blutbild?
Wie hoch die Leukozytten sind?
Ja, lecker sind.
Wie hoch der Hb ist?
Anemisch.
Ja, richtig.
Und jetzt haben Sie plötzlich ein Blutbild vorliegen,
wo Sie ein Hb-Wert von 4 sehen.
Ich fähre mit, das ist ja
ein Alarmwert für uns.
Das ist sehr niedrig.
Und mit diesem Alter, das ist...
wenn wir
nicht richtig eine
Ursache finden zum Blutung
und zur Blutung,
können wir eine bösartigen
Dinge denken.
Ja, muss nicht unbedingt sein, aber kann natürlich sein.
Sie haben alle an eine Sache nicht gedacht
oder nicht gefragt.
Und zwar, Sie haben alle gefragt, hat der
Übelkeit, hat er erbrochen, muss man ja nicht.
Aber was muss man noch fragen?
Ob der Mann Terstuhl gehabt hat?
Oder auch Fähigkeit beim Stuhlgang?
Ja, nee, Sie müssen gezielt nach Terstuhl fragen.
Der Patient, der normale Mensch
kann das nicht beurteilen.
Sie müssen die Leute direkt fragen,
haben Sie einen schwarzen Stuhl bemerkt?
Dann sagt der Mann, wenn Sie mich so fragen,
ja, der Stuhlgang war ich ziemlich schwarz
in den letzten 2 Tagen.
Und jetzt haben Sie Ihre Verdachtsteregnose.
Der Mann muss inkubeluten.
Jetzt haben Sie Ihre Verdachtsteregnose
und jetzt muss die Maschine relaufen.
Was müssen Sie bei dem Mann als Allererstes
machen in dem Falle?
Jetzt haben Sie das Epigastrium abgedrückt,
er hat Schmerzen, HB Abfall
und er sagt Terstuhl, ja, aber, aber.
Was gehört bei der Untersuchung?
Weil Verdacht auf Terstuhl immer dazu.
Direkt allen Untersuchungen?
Ja, direkt die digitale Untersuchung.
Weil Patienten sind Leien,
die können den Stuhlgang nicht richtig beurteilen.
Und Sie müssen sich vergewissern,
dass der auch tatsächlich Terstuhl hat.
Und dann machen Sie direkt die digitale Untersuchung.
Und dann sehen Sie,
der hat tatsächlich schwarzen Stuhl, Terstuhl
oder Melena.
Ja, gut.
Und dann ist der nächste Schritt das, was Sie gesagt haben.
Der muss dann schnell endoskopiert werden.
Ja, so.
Würden Sie aber jemanden mit einem HB-Wert
von vier sofort endoskopieren?
Nein, ja, so nicht direkt auch.
Ja, Blutgröße bestimmt Kreuztest machen
und ja, Vorbereitungen für Bluttransfusion.
Soll ich auch das durchfinden?
Ja, wie viel würden Sie denn geben?
Wie viel würden Sie geben?
Ja, jeder, jeder Einheit,
diese, diese, diese, diese, diese, diese, diese, diese, diese.
Ich, jeder Einheit, diese
Hammerjurgen-Werte
ja, einen, einen,
einen Punkt erörenden kann.
Ja, eine Konserve
erhöht den HB-Wert um einen Punkt, das ist richtig.
Aber, so wie ich gelernt habe,
unsere Gastrointerologen hatten immer wieder mal gesagt,
ein Ziel-HB-Wert von ungefähr
von ungefähr acht sollte angestrebt werden, wenn man jemanden spiegeln will. Das heißt,
sie müssen mindestens vier Konserven freutzen lassen. Aber haben sie das dann sofort da? Es hängt
davon ab, wie groß ihr Krankenhaus ist. Es hängt davon ab, wo ihr Krankenhaus ist. Und nicht alle
Krankenhäuser haben Konserven immer vor Ort. Manchmal müssen die von weit her geholt werden.
Was machen sie denn während dieser Zeit? Sie müssen diesen Menschen jetzt erst mal versorgen,
vorbereiten. Was gehört dann bei jemandem mit einer, ich sage mal akuten oberen
Geiblutung immer als Notfallmaßnahme dazu? Sie als Arzt, der ihn aufnimmt. Was müssen Sie mal
machen? Sie müssen immer Schritt für Schritt bestimmte Dinge erledigen. Blut haben Sie abgenommen,
Sie haben den körperlichen untersucht und jetzt müssen Sie diesen Menschen helfen. Sie legen
ihm entweder einen großflumigen Zugang oder am besten gleich zwei. Warum? Warum müssen Sie
ihm jetzt zwei oder mindestens einen großflumigen Zugang legen? Ja, diese Hämmerglobinweiter
kann lebensbedrohlich sein und deswegen haben wir hier vorhin schon immer eine Frage gekommen und
wir müssen vorbereiten sein, bereit sein, ja eine Flüssigkeit sofort. Ja, Sie müssen ihm
sogar etwas anhängen. Sie müssen ihm sogar jetzt etwas anhängen. Sie müssen dem Flüssigkeit
anhängen und was geben Sie ihm dann gleich mit dazu, wenn sie Flüssigkeit anhängen?
Okay. Ja, der Kollege hat da schon die richtige Idee. Ja, ja, das ist der roten Pumpenthema.
Ja, PPS. Das müssen Sie geben, wenn Sie den Verdacht oder wenn Sie eine gesicherte
obere Geblutung haben, dann legen Sie einen großflumigen Zugang. Sie hängen dem Mann sofort
hoch dosiert PPI an, am besten auch etwas gegen Übelkeit, falls der erbricht, dass er nicht gleich
hinter aspiriert oder andere Probleme bekommt und dann großzügig Flüssigkeit anhängen und
während dieser Zeit lassen Sie Konservenkreuz. Ja, am besten mindestens vier Stück, wenn
der sehr, sehr tief mit dem HB war. So, und dann ist Ihr nächster Schritt, was machen Sie dann?
Endoskopie. Nehmen wir mal an, der Mann kommt in der Nacht, was machen Sie dann mit dem?
Okay, soll ich in ein großen Krankenhaus verlegen oder wenn wir nicht keinen behandelten Arzt
haben oder? Es hängt davon ab, also wenn Sie in dem Krankenhaus, wo Sie arbeiten,
keine Gastroenterologie haben mit Akutintervention, dann sprechen Sie mit Ihrem Oberarzt, rufen einen
Notarzt und verlegen den in eine akute Klinik. Wenn aber in Ihrem Haus eine Akutgastroenterologie
gibt, dann rufen Sie den Dienstabenden Gastroenterologen an und dann schildern Sie ihm. Dann sagen Sie ihm,
ein Mann 60 Jahre alt, hat seit einer Woche Schlappheit, Müdigkeit und in der Blutuntersuchung
sieht man einen HB-Abfall auf 4 Gramm Podesiliter und rektal digital sieht man Terrestool. Übelkeit,
der Brecher hat er nicht und ich habe den Verdacht der hat eine obere Geblutung und
sie fragen ihn, ob er ihn jetzt akut spiegeln möchte oder nicht. Das müssen Sie machen.
Und was machen Sie jetzt mit diesem Mann? Wo ist der? Tun Sie den auf die Station, bleibt er in der
Notaufnahme oder geht er woanders hin? Ja, sollen wir stationär aufnehmen und unbedingt. Ja,
aber wohin nehmen Sie den auf? Wo hin nehmen Sie den auf? Ja, das ist, ja, so sollen wir eine
intensive Station aufnehmen oder das Überwachungsstationsreit. Ja, Überwachungsstation. Also,
wenn in einem Haus ein Überwachungsstation gibt, würde ich diesen Menschen an Überwachung tun,
damit der am Monitor ist, falls der irgendwie schockig wird, hyperboleum wird, weil sie wissen
ja nicht, wie er blutet. Wenn er sagt, er hat eine Woche und in einer Woche ist ein kerngesunder Mann
auf ein HB Wert von 4 abgefahren. Das kann jederzeit auch zu Ende gehen. Sie hängen dem
Flüssigkeit an, Sie möchten wissen, wie ist sein Blutdruck, wie ist der Atmung und wie ist der
Kreislauf, wie ist die Herzfunktion und das können Sie auf einer Überwachungsstation gut
überwachen. Wenn er jetzt irgendwie akut auch noch erbricht und der Druckabfall da ist,
dann müssen Sie dann auf die intensive Station tun. Dann binden wir sofort an Monitor an. Ja,
na klar, auf der Überwachungsstation sofort an den Monitor dran hängen. Flüssigkeit, PPI,
Überwachungsstation und Kreuzblut anhängen und im nächsten Schritt sofort die Rufbereitschaft
oder den diensthabenden Gastroenterologen anrufen, über den Patienten informieren und
nicht alleine lassen, nicht weggehen. Wenn er noch wach ist, kann man den über die Endoskopie
aufklären. Wenn er nicht so wach ist, dann ist das eine Notfallindikation, da muss man
den nicht unbedingt aufklären. Das muss man wissen. Notfall muss nicht immer aufgeklärt
werden. Aber wenn er wach ist, wenn er orientiert ist, alles versteht, würde ich immer eine Aufklärung
durchführen, aber auch immer den Vermerkmachen Notfallindikation. Warum? Weil Aufklärungen
müssen 24 Stunden später erst unterschrieben werden. Ja, jeder Aufklärung hat 24 Stunden
Bedenkzeit. Das heißt, wenn sie einen Menschen für eine Endoskopie aufklären, dann muss er nicht
sofort unterschreiben. Der hat 24 Stunden Bedenkzeit und erst dann muss er unterschrieben werden. Aber
in diesem Falle brauchen sie diese Zeit nicht, das ist eine Notfallindikation. Aber sie können
den trotzdem aufklären. Der muss aber nicht unterschreiben. Gut. Und jetzt sagt der
Gastroenterologe, der Mann ist jung, der blutet, ja, hängen Sie dem zwei Konserven sofort dran und
bestellen Sie noch zwei weitere. Ich mache mich sofort auf den Weg. Ich rufe die Rufbereitschaft,
die Endoskopie soll sich bereit machen und sobald wir da sind, rufen wir den Mann in die
Endoskopie. Ja? Und jetzt wird er gespiegelt. Jetzt guckt der Gastroenterologe in den Magen,
Speiseröhre soweit in Ordnung, Gastrosophageale Übergang soweit in Ordnung. Er sieht keinen
Tumor und siehe da im Do Denum sieht da eine Blutungsquelle, ein Ulcus. Und er sagt, er sieht
eine Sikablutung. Ja? Okay. Hören Sie mich? Jetzt höre ich. Ja? Die Blutungen, wie teilt man dir ein?
Die Forestblutungen, wenn der Mann jetzt sagt, er hat eine Sikablutung, was ist es dann? Ja? Dann
ist es eine Forest, zwei oder Einsblutung. Was ist es? Was sagen die anderen? Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Also, der Mann hat eine Sikablutung. Ja? Und was ist es dann, wenn man die Blutung nach Forest
ein teilt? Eine aktive Blutung ist immer eine Forest-1-Blutung. Wenn es spritzend ist, ist es eine
Forest-1-A-Blutung. Wenn es eine Sikablutung ist, dann ist es eine Forest-1-B-Blutung. Wenn es eine
inaktive Blutung ist, dann ist es eine Forest-2-Blutung. Und wenn es nicht mehr blutet, ohne Blutungszeichen,
Lesion, dann ist es eine Forest-3-Lesion. Ja? Und der Mann hat eine akute Forest-1-B-Blutung. Der Gastro-
antroologe unterspritzt das Ganze und sagt ihnen, jetzt müssen Sie diesen Menschen auf den Tensivstation
tun. Warum? Das kann nämlich jederzeit wieder aufgehen. Ja? Und dann kann er extrem stark bluten,
wieder schockig werden und sagt, bei dieser aktiven Blutung tun wir den lieber auf
den Tensivstationen, geben Sie dem nochmal zwei EK-S, geben Sie den Flüssigkeit und morgen früh
gucken wir nochmal rein, ob alles weiterhin stabiles ist oder nicht. So, jetzt kommen wir aber zu
der Ursache. Warum hat der Mann wohl jetzt diesen Ulcus mit dieser Blutung entwickelt?
Ja, dass der einzige Ursache kann diese Überprüferung annehmen. Ja, möglicherweise, aber der Mann
hat noch eine Voraussetzung. Stress. Stress macht er aus. Der Teamleiter. Und Stress führt meistens zu
viel Salzsäure-Bildung. Und wenn er dann noch ein PPI, einen Ibuprofen einnimmt, ein NSA-R,
dann wird die Trombozytna-Kigration auch noch gehemmt. Und das kann dann manchmal in dieser
Situation ändern, dass sie dann plötzlich so eine Blutung entwickelt. Ein Ulcus, was vielleicht
ein Gefäß angereift und dann blutet es aus einem Stumpf. So weit okay? Gut. Und jetzt wird der Mann
am nächsten Tag nochmal gespiegelt. Und der Gastroenterologe sagt, das Ganze sieht so weit
stabil aus. Der darf jetzt die Intensivstation verlassen, aber noch zwei Tage auf der
Normalstation überwachen und noch ein Ultraschall vom Bauch machen, schauen, ob alles in Ordnung ist.
Warum macht man noch ein Ultraschall? Ja, kann das auch perforationslos sein? Sehr gut. Ja, ich hätte
jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass ein Chirurg unter euch sofort antwortet, perforationsgefahr. Auch
deshalb, weil der Gastroenterologe in den Ulcus hinein manipuliert hat. Die Wand ist sehr dünn,
er kann natürlich perforieren. Dann guckt man sich eben an, ob man freie Flüssigkeit sieht,
ob da irgendwie Hinweis für eine Perforation da sind, ja oder nein, ob der Bauchschmerzen hat
oder nicht. Und dann gibt man dem weiterhin noch PPE, Anfangs intravenös. Und irgendwann
stellt man das auf Tabletten um und dann kann man diesen Menschen dann entlassen. Wenn man so jemanden
hat, wonach guckt man denn noch bei einer Endoskopie? Sie gucken, ob da ein Ulcus ist, aber was wird
automatisch einmal gemacht mittlerweile? Ich sage es Ihnen, der Helikobaktertest. Ja, natürlich,
Brust-Teste. Ja, in Helikobakter müssen Sie immer abklären, ja. Warum, weil es eine
Prägranze Rose darstellt. Und dann müssen Sie gucken, ist der positiv, ja oder nein. Wenn er positiv ist,
müssen Sie eine Erradikation empfehlen. Dafür macht man das. Ja, das darf man nie vergessen. Wenn
ein Gastroenterologe sowas macht und kein Helikobaktertest macht, hat er falsch gehandelt. Ja,
so weit okay. Sie sehen, ein Schwarz kann auch etwas ganz Einfaches, eine ganz akute Situation
darstellen. Man muss aber ganz klar fragen, klipp und klar fragen, gezielt fragen. Wenn Sie den
Patienten nicht fragen, kriegen Sie nicht die richtigen Antwort. Der Mann ist ein studierter
Mensch, sagt man, der ist Ingenieur, der ist sehr intelligent, aber man muss ihn trotzdem fragen,
er ist kein Arzt. Ja, und wenn Sie ihn nicht fragen, ob er Terstuhl hat, sagt er das nicht von sich
aus, weil er gar nicht weiß, was das ist. Er wird dann sagen, er hat, was weiß ich,
irgendeine Kirschen gegessen oder Spinat gegessen, er hat etwas gegessen und dadurch war der Stuhlgang
dunkel gewesen. Ja? Ja. Okay, noch Fragen? Ich glaube, Sie haben alles gut erzählt. Ganz
vom Anfang bis Ende. Wie teilt der Belutung ein? Ich habe Sie nicht verstanden. Wie teilt der Belutung ein?
Ja, obere gastrointestinale Blutung, ja, aus einem Brudinalulkos. Und wo ist, wo ist, wo ist unten?
Oben ist Speiseröhre, Magen, 12-Fingerdamen und untere Geblutung ist, wenn es aus dem
Dickdarmblut oder aus dem unteren Dünndarmblut. Wo ist, wo ist die Grenze? Ja, also mitten im Dünndarm,
je nachdem, wo die Blutungsquelle liegt, ja, Sie müssen den gastrointestinal Trakt in der Mitte durch
2 Teilen, alles, was oberhalb ist, oberigee Blutung und alles, was unten ist, bis untere Geblutung. Ja,
wenn da Sie den Dünndarm nicht spiegeln können, nicht normal spiegeln können, müssen Sie sagen, 12-Fingerdamen
plus Magen plus Speiseröhre ist obere Geblutung und Dickdarm und Ilyozecalklappe, vielleicht da, ist
eben untere Geblutung. Ja, ist die Tritzleger, man ist schon Grenzung oder so kann man sagen?
Kann man schon sagen, aber wie will man das denn so einfach herausfinden?
Ja, das kann ich. Dünndarm können Sie nicht spiegeln, ja, das können Sie entweder mit einer
Kapselendoskopie kontrollieren oder es gibt die sogenannte Push-Pull Technik, Push-Pull Endoskopie,
nur damit können Sie den Dünndarm spiegeln, aber das ist sehr selten und eine Dünndarmblutung
habe ich noch nie so richtig gesehen, nur wenn jemand den Tumor hat oder so, aber so normale
Blutungen sieht man meistens immer entweder im Dickdarm oder im oberen Gastrointestinalkracht,
mehr so Dodeenum oder Magen oder Speiseröhre. Weitere Fragen? Alles geklärt soweit?
Ja, es ist gut genommen. Super. Aus meiner Seite. Ja. Super, gut, dann machen wir Schluss. Dann vielen
Dank fürs Zuhören. Ich hoffe, jeder hat so ein bisschen was mitgenommen und wie gesagt,
einfach nur ganz logisch denken und Fragen stellen. Patientengespräche führen heißt immer
Fragen stellen und auch gut zuhören. Wenn man das kann, dann weiß man von vornherein,
wohin die Reise geht, wo das Problem liegt meistens. Ja, alles klar. Schönen Abend dann alle.
Ja, schönen Abend noch. Wir bedanken uns auch.